[Music]
well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pipa carrera and harry cole both with us
from now until just before midnight
welcome to both of you so to the front
pages then let us start with the
telegraph which leads with the news
tonight that the queen is to miss
tomorrow's state opening of parliament
because of her mobility issues and that
her speech will be read by prince
charles
the same story for the sun with the
headline crown and out
meanwhile get a fine we will resign the
metro leading on the pledge from the
labour leadership that they will quit if
they're fined over alleged lockdown
breaches
that story is also the lead for the time
stammer i will quit if police find me
for beer
the financial times describes the move
as kierstama's challenge to ross
johnson's integrity
as the mirror puts it this is what honor
looks like mr johnson
well the guardian describes it as
starmus gamble adding that labour say
they have compiled a dossier of evidence
proving the curry and beers were part of
a working day
the daily mail though leading on tory
mps accusing the labour leader of using
the pledge to resign as a way of
influencing the outcome of the police
investigation
the express goes with a pledge by boris
johnson to work tirelessly on his agenda
for leveling up the country
and the star leads on comments from a
former nasa chief that humans may soon
have a close encounter with aliens that
is all we need a reminder that we're
scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch the programme
so let us introduce now pippa clearer
and harry cole who are here to take us
through
and i guess two stories dominating uh
one secure stammer and the other the
queen and the queen's speech um so let's
start with uh sakir shall we uh in the
metro get a fine we will resign um why
did he do it and was it the right thing
to do harry
um he did um he did it because he didn't
have any choice um
after
months of misleading statements about
this event
uh as it's been described now in durham
last year and then a week of quite bad
tempered changing of the story
um a number of uh
of eyewitnesses coming forward um the
police opened their investigations now
a week is a long time in politics but
i'm i can remember exactly a week ago
when we were sitting on this show and
this was all described as a political
smear
uh and uh and and some sort of uh local
local elections wheeze well you know
durham police think the evidence
threshold has been met for an
investigation they say they have
significant new information about this
event and stammer has hoy's been hoisted
by zen batard he went so hard
on leave boris johnson aside let's just
look at rishi sunak kamishi sunak who
most fair observers think has been
fairly
hard done by by the met finding him for
his brief appearance in between meetings
when uh someone may or may not have sung
happy birthday to the prime minister
um stammer said he had to go he should
resign now if he were to hold stammer to
his own
bar that he set then he's the one that's
you know landed himself in this mess
because he said he set the rules of of
what of what morality in public life
means and
after a weekend of reflection i think
he's come up to comes a conclusion that
was very obvious that if he gets a fine
he's going anyway so he might as well
try and grab grapple with some semblance
of political uh capital on this
by trying to play it play it up as this
great big
moment of integrity when in fact he's
totally snooping himself well i should
have put that question to pippa who has
spoken to the man himself in the daily
mirror your exclusive pippa um what did
he say i mean i can see what the
headline says but what did he say to you
about the reasons he felt this was
necessary and how they think they've
handled this
so kyou starman believes that
when the police decided that they were
going to investigate this not um
as harry says significant new
information i think rather than evidence
there's a difference new information my
understanding is that when they realized
that angela had been there they
thought perhaps that they should look
closer because previously obviously the
party had had denied that she was
present and also the fact that uh two of
kyo stoma's
police protection officers were nearby
and as we know from partygate and number
10 the minute police integrity or
collusion is raised as a as a
possibility that the police want to make
sure that their names aren't dragged
into it so we're extra keen to look into
it so the police decided on friday that
they were going to um to look at this um
obviously they decided they had said in
february that they didn't think that it
meant the thresholds for
investigation they changed their minds
um
there has as harry rightly said been a
relentless campaign in the run-up to
local elections in the right-wing press
about um about this incident last year
um and the first uh kyocera heard a bit
he told me today was when the police put
out a press release in fact the police
didn't get in touch with labour until
today
we don't know yet it's really a question
for the police as to whether they will
interview him directly or whether they
will ask him to fill out a questionnaire
but he was very adamant that as far as
he was concerned the rules hadn't been
broken but it is the case that this is a
big gamble because if the police come to
another conclusion he has now put
himself in a position where he has to go
now i think
that he would have had to have gone
anyway and he's making the as harry says
making the most out of the situation but
he has spent his whole
leadership um defining himself as a man
of principle and integrity as opposed to
prime minister who i don't think even
harry would argue that
he's a man of principle and integrity um
so if you if you
if you set yourself out with that sort
of stark divide
with um your opponent then you have to
maintain that course and
uh obviously it was unsustainable for
him to be in a position where he um he
could have called for boris johnson to
go
um and then not go himself if he was
fined and i know that the rishi
synapkies i think is sorry rightly
rightly flags is a bit different um but
of course um didn't actually ask for him
to go
until he was fined i don't think anybody
including washington expected him to be
fined boris johnson was different he
called for him to go previously and
there's lots of detail in the article
tomorrow as to what actually happened on
that night okay well we'll come if you
don't mind giving us a bit of that
detail that'll be brilliant i just want
to mention the daily mail beer gate day
13 it's them that put a lot of the
pressure on all through sort of the
run-up to the local elections last week
as well um they've really been going for
it have they not cornered labour leader
they say um and a picture of him also on
the front page of the telegraph too uh
you know head bowed uh you know to stand
out if he's fine they say now the danger
for him as part of this is one people it
it continues the story of how this was
handled by him and others but also the
nuance of all of this honor business and
integrity is possibly lost on a lot of
people they'll hear beer curry and
they'll hear you know rule breaking and
resign and they won't necessarily hear
the i'm doing the right thing by you
know by the rules that as they were laid
down at the time
you know do you do you agree this is the
gamble for him harry or is he actually
damaged by this already yeah he's
totally damaged by this he's he he talks
a very good game of being this man of
honor or integrity but he's lied twice
about this event now he said angela
reyna was not there and she was through
a spokesperson admittedly he went on
television last week and said they had
to get a takeaway because nothing else
was open that wasn't true then we find
out the weekend because his own side has
started to say actually he's telling
porkys about this and start leaking the
actual schedule from his from his day
where it turns out this pre-arranged
dinner was in his diary for um for an
hour and a half at the end of the day
after the campaigning had been done it
was in his diary very clearly dinner
with an mp now they're going to come out
and say well we were working we went
back to work that that these are the
same sort of tired excuses that boris
johnson tried boris johnson was very
adamant all the way up until he got a
fine that no rules have been broken they
have to say that
until until it's been proved
comprehensively one way or the other by
the police
more than 50 police fines plus multiple
what is it 16 different occasions
including cakes and invites and bring
your own booze does that does that
equate to the beer that is being held in
his hand no but i'm not i'm not equating
i'm not equating i'm not equating it to
what happened in downing street i'm i'm
judging
and the public will judge kirstama by
his own rules his own words now
a lot of those things in downing street
got to the level of a police
investigation because it turned out the
prime minister's vanity photographer was
spraying the camera all over the place
and there's picture evidence there is
very clear picture evidence of what
looks like kierstarma having a nice time
inside with his mates having a beer the
onus is on him now to prove that that
work was actually done and it's a fairly
rubbish attempt to do so in the guardian
tomorrow where they're claiming some
aids not kirsten himself some aides were
sending some whatsapp at some point that
day on that evening therefore they were
definitely working i think that's let's
try a little harder than that okay well
it's less of pippa as we as we float
through the mat cartoon if we can which
is durham labour party stayed two proper
doms apart is there a attempt to joke at
this one just very quickly then the
detail of what did happen
um you know why did it come out in dribs
and drabs and why did they forget things
like angela rainer being there for
example pepper i think i think harry's
allegations about kirsten are lying and
putting a bit strongly the labour party
admitted that angelarina they'd
mistakenly said the press office and of
course he said he's taken he told me he
takes responsibility for this that she
wasn't there but it wasn't kyostara
himself he didn't even know that denial
taken place until um last week um the uh
the fact that the
the work that was an op note i mean
that's standard practice you ask any
politician and harry and i have both
been on the campaign trail millions of
times you ask any politicians somebody's
put in charge of feeding the politician
otherwise you survive on the campaign
trail on crisps not kyostarma himself
it's just part of the working day it's
also the case as i think the mail and
the mail on sunday both conceded that um
there wasn't anywhere else to eat the
hotels did stop serving food despite
suggestions in the sun last week at nine
o'clock and that um
and that uh
the work as we know is boris johnson
knows probably better than me than most
that work when you're on the campaign
trail carries on around the clock and
kirsten told me this afternoon that when
he'd eaten his curry not standing around
having a jolly with his mates but having
a beer in a curry and then getting back
to work um he was looking at the
schedule for the day ahead he was
talking to the individuals concerned
about the visits that he was making as
part of that local election and hospital
by-election tour um he had his sort of
piles of papers that he had to go
through some speeches he was making and
media events that he had and that's and
that's what he was doing and they're
going to share all that information with
the police so they'll be able to make up
their mind yeah just very very quickly
if it was if it was a bottle of water in
his hand would this have just would this
have been is it is it all about the
bottle of
beer because who bought the beer
who bought the beer well somebody
somebody who is responsible for doing
the curry but that's not the leader
if it's 15 people 15 to 30 up to up to
30. we're settling on 15
someone brought a load of beers in but
that's that i mean this is just use the
same standards that you held downing
street to for their parties you were
suggesting that the fact that beer was
bought or booze bought it was suggested
as some sort of premeditated lock down
breaking social event now
we made a very clear distinction between
um people that had a drink at the desk
in the course of the working day i was
as i'm sure you were told about
countless examples of that taking place
across government and we made a
conscious decision not to publicize
those stories because we didn't think
that was breaking the rules what we did
do was where there was a specific social
event an organized quiz bring your own
booze um a birthday party a party the
prime minister's flat we made the
distinction because of course people
could have lost wine at the
probably but it comes down it in a sense
it comes down to the beer which is
interesting in itself but anyway we will
we will return to this but we need to do
other news after the break including the
news that the queen will miss the state
opening parliament for the first time in
very nearly 60 years back with that in
just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me once again the
political editors of the daily mirror
and the sun pepakura and harry cole um
so we turned to the queen's health and
the queen's speech in fact um and uh
well the sun is the first story um queen
misses speech for first time in 59 years
and the crowning out is that because we
just won't get to see the glitz tomorrow
if prince charles is there harry
look i think we'll get the old pumps
pomp and circumstance um
regardless this was obviously uh weeks
and months in the planning the the
queen's speech the annual address that
sets out the government's legislative
agenda for the year but that plans had
um always taken into account that the
fact is the queen um you know is is
elderly and the risk was that she would
have to
see this event go the way of
lots of others in recent times i feel a
little bit like there is a sort of view
at the palace to
uh preserve another massive event uh
next month jubilee at a historically
unprecedented event one that has
literally been years in the planning
millions of pounds
loads of events across the country lots
of things for the queen to do
if she if she's resting up for that
that's hopefully
you know that that's what it is and not
something worse but um
this was slightly disability issues
presumably you'll know more than most of
us that it's quite a hard place to get
around is it westminster if you're if
you are struggling to get up steps and
things like that
it is but also
the ceremony does involve a very long
walk uh down the that from the from the
from the gates to the seats so i think
they had looked at shortening it but um
it's clear even that wasn't possible
so we go to the content of the uh the
queen's speech to be delivered obviously
by prince charles um daily express i
will strive night and day to level up
britain and the guardian too talking
about these new powers to uh
you know to to draw a line on guerrilla
protesting as as they call it
pippa oh 30 seconds oh my goodness 30
seconds quickly
well super quickly it's the law to
protest which of course ran into such
trouble in the house of lords previously
and because it managed to get blocked
that particular aspect of it by the
house of lords boys johnson is
reintroducing it this session it'll
basically lock people up for six months
if they lock themselves to building in a
year if they into the interrupt um key
or disrupt key national infrastructure
likely to run into more trouble than
those words but the pm is determined to
push it through loads of coverage
tomorrow both of you thank you
[Music]